nous devons évacuer l'immeuble
génial j'ai besoin de vous je reste ici
je parle pas un ouragan de catégorie 5
qui arrive tu as l'air d'avoir oublié il
est déjà classés en 5
[Musique]
votre père ne veut pas partir madame je
peux pas le forcer à ce que je vous
demande c'est d'y retourner avec moi et
mes d aller va créer de cet immeuble
croyez-vous grouillez vous montez
douce marc cherry hill soro
il fait partie d'une bande qui commet
les bras car je leur obole
koné blessé de choper ces [ __ ] et de
+1 boire
vous savez ce qu'ils veulent ce type
j'ai ma petite idée oui
50 millions de dollars il est ici dans
cet immeuble l'argent du crime si on
veut avoir une toute petite chance il
nous faut le plus d'armes possibles
offerts étage par étage de ce casque on
est trop
et ensuite ils vont tous ou décembre
[Musique]
on est dans l'oeil du cyclone mais si
vous voulez faire vos preuves
ces mamans
pourquoi
[Musique]
j'étais fait exploser les classes et je
me porte bien
et n'oubliez pas on tirent pour tuer
c'est lent travail petit